how would you change the perks the
Kickstarter well one of the worst things
that Kickstarter perks has any snow the
model that they built but how people use
it is that you know if you pay 10 to 15
or maybe 20 dollars for a DVD on a store
why are you paying 30 for one in
Kickstarter because what because of its
an indie project because it's the what's
up with that why the minimal amount just
to appear in the credits it's ten
dollars or five dollars for a thank you
it's like dude I mean look at the market
freecell if you want but why people I
mean what are you making people pay more
and you know if if your if your target
audience for the Kickstarter campaign or
people that is related to cool and new
things that's alright because you know
it's like an added value they're gonna
they're not gonna you know they're gonna
spend it but for normal people if you
wanna reach like it bro audience just
presale as you were in the market
competing to all the people and all the
DVDs and of films and at the same time
perks you know they give you a lot of
work a lot of work and if that's the
only way to find your film you're not
gonna find your film you know for the
corner from from strictly crowdfunding
like selling merchandise we rise like
fifty thousand dollars half of that went
to pay for the stock of the same you
know t-shirts on the the mailing and
everything else and the other half would
have gone to pay the guys that were
making packages for five thousand people
for two years so in the end there's no
money for the film you know we got the
real money for an investment from from
crowd investment you know people from an
internet that were you know buying a
percentage of a film but the rest was
just promotion which is great if you
take it that way it's like okay let's
promote the film
let's go not so t-shirt because you know
that's gonna be people worrying
which of the film and telling about it
but to get real money out of those
difficult
you